plus de la moitié des dépenses des
caisses d'assurance maladie provient des
frais hospitaliers
le conseil des ministres a adopté un
certain nombre de mesures pour réduire
les dépenses des hôpitaux les hôpitaux
qui font aujourd'hui figure d'accusé des
déclarations qui ne satisfont pas les
responsables de la fédération
hospitalière française des déclarations
aussi qu'il considère comme un faux
procès à leur égard eh bien sans doute
pouvait ton analyse est d'un peu plus
près préalablement les résultats réels
des hôpitaux publics nous considérons
pour avoir demandé 13,9 que la dépense
actuelle ne dépasse pas 13,8 et même le
nombre de journées a diminué de l'ordre
de 3% c'est-à-dire que nous avons réduit
de 3% l'hospitalisation d'un an
les durées de séjour des malades dans
les hôpitaux ont également
considérablement diminué passant de 20
jours il y a dix ans à douze jours
maintenant et pour les grands hôpitaux
les trente centres hospitaliers
universitaires nous ne sommes qu'à neuf
jours toute discipline réunie et par
conséquent nous récusons formellement
l'accusation qui nous est fait n'est pas
d'être les fossoyeurs de la sécurité
sociale à cet égard